[Music]
bombur's is fast very chaotic
everybody's on a machine and there is no
moment to pause the taxi is essentially
I think the quiet like the hard line of
travel in Mumbai
people from all caste community takes
the taxi that's why I felt that it was
truly like a mass communication medium
[Music]
I'm son Keith of Lonni I'm a designer
our director I'm based in Mumbai design
as an industry heard it's still very new
it's it's naive and the value for it is
very understated I wanted to design a
taxi and that's where the project
started putting art in in the public
space like a taxi can exist as a
storytelling medium I think a lot of
these social issues that exist today in
India and even in Mumbai continue to
exist because of lack of communication
and that taxi fabric we decided that we
would work with designers who sort of
invested their time in coming up with
design solutions for social good we've
done in the taxi with road safety
learning the Indian sign language being
more inclusive towards students with
special needs watching this I we worked
on this taxi that talks about women's
rights
today you talk to people and I go yeah a
women has her place in the men had his
role and that's how it is and that's how
it's going to be but no one really asked
why the question here is Cappadocia
perennial love you hair which means do
do these rules apply on men as well so I
just want to - stop that thought even if
it plants a seed you mean it's sparks a
discussion that's fine these
conversations about social good it can
lead to a change of of mindset
we've tried to communicate through
design we've tried to do it in a medium
that is you know almost like an
equalizer at a local texting but that
isotope is a bad Kotani texia might
happen Satriani Callaway we get executed
program with you both as hell at the
head the passenger but the bad Kurt am
say who's okay chalica those are bad
culture
well a circus meter all of these
conversation starters sort of amplifying
through taxis will eventually at least
ask the right questions if this gets the
right support I feel that it could it
could lead to social change yeah in the
small town outside of Mumbai
there's a school
and in the school are adorable grannies
this is India's first school for
grandmother's everyday elderly women
come to a school called a jibe a cheese
shava for the education they missed out
on earlier in life margin arson and
other ticketed my je way posture study
but you wonder Harold an amazing land
panel Virgin Mother
well shall aid our ánotá because most
girls weren't allowed to go to school
they could only dream of an education so
you for Sue Ellen Langer seventeen
divided our girl in Morada Scarola hope
my director sisters
Prakash more a margin shook sugar my
jeppesen Lonnie but still Virginia hey
my deepest wound on a metal of food
mandating the fizzy would actually live
that many Merida gone unless I you gotta
think that another more upset I don't
think that that of attalos on that
unable to sign their names important
documents their whole lives the women
show off their signature with great
pride today and for most of them getting
to attend school is one of the best
parts of their day completely watching
my [ __ ] I don't know get over each our
version Margie not Marah best car a
llama discourtesy Marah best characters
locked on to the school for granny's is
only a one-year program many of the
women have plans
neither education madhavendra you want I
take potentially death mortgage clip
raggedy Holly so gradual injuries are
abiding ambassador coupe motto hi
[Music]
in India you have 700,000 villages and
each village has at least two or three
bends there is no marriage without a man
there is no death without Caban there is
no butter fill out the band and bands
they need instruments roughly 90% of
india's brass band instruments come from
this musical alley jolly Cote Lane in
the city of Meerut very Cody Lane has
about 100 manufactures but one of the
most renowned is nadir alley company mr.
naturally was my uncle started this
company in 1885 he was the first man who
started a band in India here is the
first band in 1900 with 24 people it was
immensely liked by the Indian people and
his uncle wasn't the only one with a
passion for the family business
my father's father my father myself and
all my children so you can say the
fourth generation is here we make brass
band musical instruments like trumpets
coordinates a phone IAM cuba and also
percussion instruments like drums and
things like that
you see in instrument making is an art
our instruments are the best because we
use a system of quality control the most
important thing in making instrument is
the composition of brass the material
quality the instruments from here go to
many countries anywhere from Saudi
Arabia to
Germany to France I have devoted my life
and making instruments music is the
elixir of life when you play and you you
concentrate and you play a good fuel or
hear a good tune to think you're out of
this party music is something but you
listen to it and you're lost [ __ ] they
prepare BMP just aquellos animal I am a
Jacob
[Music]
here are the mileage his hope and a
limiter the Madaba map ie Bob of tar
sing mahakal South Austin Santo bodybag
a panda but anthem Alamitos passive
Anand a Maharajah mean wanna main pocket
O'Shaughnessy kiddy
[Music]
but the rover may happen in the style
the malossi old poet as you may know the
malossi all new sunday cheese have to
condemn elog dizzy italian material
pocket arroba remember your arabic al
hakam beloved Abba yattaman open wanna
get out the innovati huzzah manoeuvre
watch our Java Yakov Atika if the cookie
Nicky not the star that Java pocket
echidna Java and over to the photo photo
photo America's original jjigae Europe
and Republicans America's enemy kusabi
OSA
Menno pakistani mehndi body cozy olya
olvidar may kiss a ptarmigan in the
avocado ben de poder de ba ba di di
biagio Bonilla a port rd Ghana
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a product of the Lodi arm alone no
way another one what you want to tell a
little get-together in Chennai India
there's a tiny camera repair shop run by
a man named Joseph say car and I had the
sega and brigitte bardot is not the
Birdman Andre say car got his nickname
because every day he feeds thousands of
hungry parakeets on the roof of his home
he wondered the end of marketing idea
Lemuria over we reaffirm our Quran Allah
Allah Allah Allah Almighty
[Music]
the 2006 tsunami that hit Southeast Asia
flooded parts of India and displaced
thousands of birds sake are noticed a
pair of parakeets outside of his home
and set some rice out for them then more
started to show up and well even during
the poisoning deflect up all day
everybody and the worried 8000 target so
they're feeding 8,000 pair keeps twice a
day is a great expense say car spends
about 40 percent of the money he makes
from repairing cameras buying food for
the birds
you know do a lot cheaper download is a
party but for the Birdman of Chennai
there's more to life than money
fernanda I'll kill em upon I want to
tear it up anime volcano one thing over
money thing to get ever come out there
Wikimedia selected a part of the
metagame de la supported them you know
what we're in I'm gonna give me the
anomaly we say under more to use on my
car normally you know Ricardo Miata
moving yellow we don't like it no we
don't die anymore d MC escher has
nothing on this place Qian Bao D is one
of the largest and perhaps most visually
spectacular stepwells this deep
four-sided structure is made up of 3500
s you're asked terraced steps that
descend down to a depth of 100 feet
a large temple adorns the face dedicated
to Harshad Mehta goddess of joy and
happiness
you may recognize this incredible wonder
it's intricate steps have made
appearances in Hollywood films like the
fall The Dark Knight Rises and the Best
Exotic Marigold Hotel northwestern India
where the step well lies is extremely
arid the well was designed to conserve
as much water as possible at the bottom
of the well the air remains 5 degrees
cooler than at the surface making it an
excellent gathering place for locals
during intense heat waves
[Music]
you
[Music]